okay phil thomas wants to know what led
him what led you professor to the field
of mathematics and is your field
something you think virtually anyone can
learn
what led me there
you know
it's a question about my life story
right so what led me there is
essentially is is
um
a sequence of uh coincidences and
misunderstandings i don't know
a number of things but
so
um
to some extent to some extent i was good
at that
and that
pushed me to do more of it
and that's a very common answer for very
many things right people tend to do what
they're good at
misunderstandings you said
misunderstandings as well yes to some
extent uh
i misunderstood math so
you know there was a time that i really
liked uh computers and electronics
and i uh at some point
realized that there is a lot of kind of
hard work in it
so
uh
writing a computer program is very hard
you have to write hundreds of lines of
code and then uh debug them and they
whatever and similarly for electronics
right you have to place those
transistors on the board and solder them
together and uh
solder them together and uh and you
always get it wrong and you know there
is a lot of hard work where mathematics
is so much easier all you have to do is
to prove theorems
that was a complete misunderstanding i
mean i thought it was like
much purer
uh i didn't
at the time i didn't realize how much
hard work is involved
so in some sense i go there i go to
mathematics by misunderstanding by being
lazy and not realizing that
i'm
getting trapped into in into a place
where laziness is is not
it is is not always enough
and also at the end i ended up liking
those parts that i first thought i was
going away from namely computation
so i ended up i mean computation to me
was like a childhood thing and a later
acquired taste
there was a period in between when in
between when i thought i was pure i
would never compute anything
um
right what else did i answer or did i
mean there was a second part to the
question do you believe that your field
either the field of mathematics or your
subfield the one that you're working in
currently do you feel that your field is
something that virtually anyone can
learn
no
uh so
uh
some
some amount of mathematics
everybody can learn
and everybody should learn
and maybe it's more
than what is taught in
uh
in our current educational system
education system okay
but
um
you know i
i will never catch up with ed whitton
okay
the
the amount of stuff that he knows the
depth of the stuff the
the depth by which he knows things
i'll never get there
it's not i'm not talented enough to get
there
it might be that in my 30 years in the
subject i've learned things that
most people
also wouldn't be able to catch up with
so um
you know um
there is the mushizuki proof of the abc
conjecture
disputed
okay moshizuki claims it's a proof other
people think it isn't
i will never be in the position to
understand that
i mean
possibly if i started early enough i'm
not even sure
i happen to know moshizuki i remember
him when he was young we we were friends
when like we went where went to graduate
school together
so i uh
so i remember him when he was young
he was smarter and faster than me
it's conceivable that after 20 years
he's gone so far
that i will never be able to catch up
it's equally possible that
there are people who would never be able
to catch up with me
[Music]
they said
some amount of mathematics
is useful to everybody
you know
we're we're now in the in the midst of a
pandemic
understanding what's the exponential
function
is something that
uh
is basic knowledge is something that
every human should
should have
because it actually dictates if it tells
us something a about how to behave
uh at this time
uh
likewise making various probabilistic
estimates
you know uh
if the chance of such and such type of
side effects is is one in a million what
does it mean
what does one in a million means in
practical term for me terms for me
should i fear it
or is it so remote that i have that i
can ignore it
uh so basic numeracy is is is is an
absolute necessary ingredient and for
everyone and can be reached by everyone
when you mention that you'll never be
able to catch up to witton and may
perhaps some people won't be able to
catch up to you and so on
what is that a function of biology you
mentioned the word talent so is it is
that just innate is
is what's innate called intelligence is
that associated with iq like
what are you referring to when you say
you won't be able to catch up
it's a number of things
you can call it talent
you can call it iq if you wish but of
course there is no numerical measurement
and it's a much much more complicated
thing so um
you know so much of
how far you can get in mathematics
depends on how much you concentrate on
mathematics
so you know uh
maybe when you're
uh
if at a certain part of your life you're
able to completely isolate yourself and
think on nothing but mathematics
you'll end up knowing more mathematics
than if you are also a human a human
along
alongside okay uh
so
uh
so
so so talent is also
circumstance and
uh
in luck
and
in some sense being narrow-minded
somehow being narrow-minded helps in
certain ways
speaking of eric weinstein you mentioned
him
okay so so
so he was very unbalanced he had great
talent for certain kind of things and
great fear of others
and
maybe he would have been a much more
famous mathematician physicist now
if if it wasn't for these
coincidences
so
um
i don't know
i mean
you could call it
innate you could call it
uh learn you can call it many things but
it's a very complicated combination of
things